héritière et praticienne émérite de ce
que l'on appelle l'art sociologique
sophie calle organise des expositions
animé dans lesquelles des hommes et des
femmes jouent un rôle c'est force
d'incarner ce qu'elle leur a demandé
elle publie aussi des livres qui rendent
compte de ses travaux à la fois loufoque
et sérieux est en tout cas suffisamment
dérangeant pour qu'un mode d'emploi
accompagnent ces coffrets toujours
élégamment édité par actes sud
les dormeurs ce sont donc deux volumes
sous emboîtage dans le premier la règle
du jeu
sophie calle a demandé à 28 personnes de
venir successivement dormir dans son
propre lit au cours d'une semaine où
quelques minutes ou pour une nuit et
d'accepter de répondre à des questions
et surtout de se laisser photographier
pendant leur sommeil
le premier volume raconte donc ses 28
moments vécus par des inconnus ou des
personnalités comme roland topor ou
fabrice luchini deuxième volume
les photographies de ces corps endormi
et les commentaires qu en donne sophie
calle
pourquoi ces gens ont-ils accepté une
aussi étrange proposition est bien
précisément parce qu'il ne l'aurait
jamais imaginé le résultat très
troublant montre l'abandon la confiance
le malaise aussi si c'est bien l'une des
fonctions de l'arc de décaler le regard
visuel alors sophie calle est une
artiste